Understanding South Africa's
Genocide Case Against Israel Part Four:
How the World is Reacting.
Many countries have openly supported
South Africa's case against Israel,
including the 57 countries
of the Organization of Islamic Cooperation,
who issued a statement of support
and accused Israel of
“indiscriminate targeting” of civilians.
Other countries
that have publicly supported
the case are
Bolivia, Malaysia, Pakistan,
Namibia, Nicaragua, Venezuela.
Meanwhile, the West
has been pretty united
in condemning South Africa for this.
The United States, Israel's oldest
ally, called the case unproductive
and the genocide allegations unfounded.
Canada, Germany and the U.K.
all insisted
that Israel has the right
to defend itself
and rejected the genocide claims.
The French foreign minister
said that
accusing Israel of genocide,
“cross[es] a moral threshold.”
Ultimately, it's
this international court’s job to decide
if South Africa's claims have any merit.
But remember that the court doesn't
have any way of enforcing it.
In part five,
I'll explain what's next for this case.